افاد مراس العربيه بسماع دوي انفجارات
متتاليه في عموم المناطق شمال غرب سوريا
وحلب هذا وقال النظام السوري ان غاره جويه
اسرائيليه استهدفت مطار حلب الدوري مع ادى
الى وقوع بعض الاضرار الماديه في المطار
واوضح مراسل العربي ان القصف الاسرائيلي
استهدف المطاره باربعه صواريخ ما ادى الى
توقف حركه الملاحه الجويه وهذا ثالث هجوم
على مطار حلب خلال سته اشهر
العربيه محمد الاشقر اهلا بك محمد ماذا
تقول المعطيات حول هذه الغارات محمد
وطبيعه الاهداف التي قصفت ايضا اليوم
نعم يعني في الحقيقه اليوم
استهدف تستهدفت الصواريخ الاسرائيليه مطار
حلب الدولي شرق حلب بصواريخ اطلقت من غرب
مدينه اللاذقيه من قباله السواحل السوريه
باتجاه المطار مما ادى الى حدوث اضرار
داخل المطار وتوقف حركه الملاحه فيه
وخروجه عن الخدمه بشكل جزئي طبعا وزاره
الدفاع التابعه للنظام اصدرت عبر صفحتها
الرسميه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وقالت ان المطار تعرض لغاره جويه
اسرائيليه تسببت بحدوث اضرار ماديه داخل
المطار طبعا بحسب المعلومات الوارده حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يتم تسجيل اي اصابه بشريه
في داخل نتيجه هذا هذا الهجوم طبعا بحسب
المعلومات التي وصلتنا فان الاستهداف كان
لشحنه اسلحه
ايرانيه طبعا هنا بحسب شهود العيان في
محيط المطار قالوا ان
عده انفجارات متتاليه سمع دويها في المطار
بعد سقوط الصواريخ احدها كان انفجار ضخم
هذا الامر يشير الى الى
حدوث انفجار بمستودع اسلحه وذخائر او ما
شابه ذلك طبعا بحسب مصادر مطلعه على حركه
المطارات في عموم شمال في عموم سوريا
قالوا ان
طائره نقل
اقلعت من مطار دمشق يوم قبل يوم امس في
العشرين من الشهر الجالي
في مطار النيرب العسكري المجاور لمطار حلب
الدولي وبقيت في المطار مده ثمانيه ساعات
لتعود
باتجاه مطار دمشق الدولي طبعا
خلال يوم امس رصدت حرق حركه بين مطار
النيرب العسكري ومطار حلب الدولي في محيط
هذه
المنطقه يرجح ترجح هذه المصادر ان هذه
الطائره كانت محمله بالاسلحه والذخائر
التي اتجهت من دمشق الى هذه المنطقه